ني
أريد أن أرى صورة حمام عام في جواري في اليابان
من السهل الاعتقاد أن متجر الحلويات القديم مناسب تمامًا ، لكنه يتجول والميناء قديم.
فهمت
على العكس من ذلك ، فقد أصبحت مقدسة لجيل الشباب ، لذلك في مثل هذا المكان
هل هناك حاجة جديدة؟
ني
اه اه اه
أنا ميزوكي تاناكا ، أنت تغير الطلاء في المعركة.
الدوري الاميركي للمحترفين
القتال في اليابان
إنه رجل تدفق يمكن للجميع الدخول إليه.
دومو
في الأيام الماضية
يبدو أنه كانت هناك عادة التصرف في الحمام دينيا.
من هناك ، تتجذر ثقافة أن تصبح محترفًا تدريجيًا وتقاتل.
عندما كان اقتصاد كاشا جيدًا ، كنت أقوم ببناء مبنى فخم للغاية يشبه المعبد.
لأن هذا النوع من الثقافة الرائعة قد ترسخ
بعد كل شيء ، هناك بعض البلاط الجميل مثل هذا.
يتم الاستمتاع بهذا النوع من المكان
فيما يتعلق بأسلوب تأجيل السنتات ، كتبت لوحات المناظر الطبيعية ، لكنني غالبًا ما كنت أكتب جبل فوجي.
زيادة
مجموعة بيضاء ذات سماء زرقاء وعمها أزرق ، جبل أخضر في جبل بعيد في منظر طبيعي بجانب الماء
هناك الكثير من الألوان من هذا القبيل.
[موسيقى]
أتساءل ما يسمى بخصم الحجز للوحات الرسام سانت.
متوسط
حتى اليوم عندما سافرت إلى مناطق مختلفة أثناء وجودي في طوكيو ، هناك بعض الاختلافات.
هناك شيء مثل فرحة الاتصال بعالم جديد من خلال التكرار ، لذلك شيء من هذا القبيل
يقال أنه يمكنك الاستمتاع بالنظر إليه بشكل غامض والشعور بالإيجابية مرة أخرى.
أعتقد أن هذا النوع من الأشياء مهم للغاية.
المشكلة الوحيدة التي أواجهها هي الوضع الذي أكون فيه في المنزل ، وكان القتال العنيف موجودًا منذ سبعينيات القرن الماضي.
هناك أوقات عندما يتناقص باطراد
العيش كحرفي مكلف نسبيًا في اليابان
أتساءل عما إذا كان هذا هو الحال لأنه أصبح نمطًا ذا شكل غير عادي.
لكن
نتحدث اليوم
الضيوف قادمون أيضًا
بطريقة ما ، أستخدم الإنترنت لنشر المعلومات.
لقد رأى الكثير من الناس الكتابة الفعلية لبنكاي في الأحداث ، وما إلى ذلك ، وهناك عدد غير قليل من اليسار.
أعتقد أنه يمكنني الذهاب ، لكن هذا تحدٍ
هذا صحيح ، إلخ.
السبب في أنني أستمر في القيام بهذا العمل هو أنه من الممتع الكتابة
عندما انتهيت من الكتابة ، اتضح أنه عالم جديد حقًا.
هناك نوع من الفرح
[موسيقى]